GPU prices are falling is what I would
say if not for the RTX 3090 TI nvidia's
latest end
greatest look at this thing it is
massive just look at the cooler it's
like three slots maybe three and a half
and I think there's like eight separate
heat pipes here
it's bound to be the most powerful
consumer card ever
but this time we don't want to be a part
of the hype machine that sells these
things
let me explain what I mean but first let
me tell you about a sponsor smart deploy
smart deploy provides out of the box
Windows Imaging support for over 1500
computer models deploy One windows image
to any hardware model with ease get your
free licenses worth over 500 at
smartdepoint.com Linus
[Music]
we'll be comparing the new tie to the
only GPU we really need to the RTX 3090
which is quite close in specification to
the new Big Boy here
so close in fact that I had to triple
check my notes yes both have 24 gigs of
gddr6x memory but the ti pulls ahead of
memory bandwidth to almost but not quite
a terabyte per second it also boasts an
extra 2.4 percent more GPU cores that
are thankfully clocked 10 to 12 percent
higher and draws a staggering 29 higher
total Graphics power at 450 watts to
achieve that Nvidia has resorted to a
Triple Eight pin to 12 pin dongle with a
hefty 850 watt power supply requirement
they recommend a kilowatt
hoping our GPU test bench can handle
that kind of load in F1 2021 we're
looking at a roughly eight or nine
percent improvement over the RTX 3090
with Ray tracing disabled of course
which translates into about 10 FPS when
we enable Ray tracing the extra cores
work their magic for a good 13
Improvement keeping things much closer
to 60fps maxed out at 4K
Far Cry 6 sees a slightly less
impressive result at around five or six
percent with Ray tracing disabled and
just a little bit more with Ray tracing
turned on like the RTX 3090 Nvidia says
that 8K gaming is one of the 390 TI's
strong suits but when I tried it out F1
2021 chugged it around 30 FPS so I
didn't bother testing any further maybe
productivity will show us a better
example of how the power of the 3090 TI
will improve your life
blender hmm doesn't seem to think so
we're looking at a few seconds at most
depending on what renderer you're using
v-ray gives the 3090 TI a slight lead
too although the RTX result is over 100
points more so hooray pull four percent
lead
octane renderer gave us a similar kind
of situation to these as well it's
whatever moving on to power we ran five
laps of F1 2021 as a typical gaming load
and we saw a power draw Spike as high as
480 Watts that cannot cannot be right
480 Watts really holy
yeah and the average was over 400 not
much lower than the peak wattage the RTX
3090 Drew in the same test to be fair to
Nvidia while that's an absurd amount of
power more than an entire PC with a low
end GPU might draw it's roughly in line
with the performance Improvement we saw
in that game so you're getting frames
proportionally in exchange for the extra
juice if the rumors are to be believed
we'll see even more power draw in search
of higher frame rates when the next
Generation rolls out
speaking of which why is this GPU only
launching now when the 40 series Ada
Lovelace gpus are supposedly right
around the corner
well I've got a few theories maybe this
is an indication that ADA isn't right
around the corner and nvidia's trying to
make do with what they've got
or maybe the 3090 TI was delayed for so
long during the Silicon shortage that
it's launching way later than they
planned or maybe they just had high Bend
gpus kicking around that they wanted to
clear out before Ada hit later this year
our screwdriver and backpack are
hittingly this year too sign up at
ltdstore.com to be the first to know
when they're ready
you clear at angle is a very likely one
IMO nvidia's existing A40 a data center
GPU shares most of its spec sheet with
the 3090 TI albeit with a significantly
lower board power and more but slower
memory sure enough the Nvidia control
panel even has an ECC memory support
toggle like you might find on one of
those cards
while I don't have a problem with this
in principle I do have a problem with
the price they're asking for it and I'm
not comfortable with how much power this
thing is capable of drawing
starting at two thousand dollars U.S
MSRP the EVGA won't be tested costs
2200. you're looking at a 25 premium or
more over a GPU that is already priced
like a Titan and already is not
proportionally faster than the next card
down the stack for the money Nvidia
wants us to compare against the Titan
RTX a card that already wasn't worth the
price when it launched and which didn't
even live up to the Titan name with its
crippled fp64 performance that card like
this one has more in common with the
Titan XP a card that also had crippled
fp64 performance and launched at twelve
hundred dollars U.S 300 less than the
RTX 3090 that is the RTX tax in a
nutshell and calling this a 500 price
drop from the Titan RTX is a slap in the
face to anyone who thought that the 3090
itself was already making that
comparison
it's one thing to have a Halo product
for the die hards but when even that
product gets eclipsed in terms of
pricing
that's when we journey into the Absurd
if many people thought that Nvidia had
jumped the shark with the RTX 3090s 1500
price tag then they're now trying to see
just how big a shark they can clear with
the 3090 TI
especially with competition from EMD and
Intel on the horizon and with the RTX
3090 coming back down to earth in price
it feels like a cynical cash grab no
matter what their intention was
you'd be forgiven for losing track of
just what gpus even cost anymore with
how crazy pricing has been over the past
couple of years after all as recently as
this month RTX 3090s were going for over
three grand sometimes over four easily
double their original asking price
now that's finally changing the RTX 3090
is routinely going for 2K or less
someone even got really lucky on this
one and so Nvidia read the room full of
wary Gamers and professionals trying to
catch a break
and with a straight face bragged to
their investors that people were paying
more for new gpus while slapping an
astronomical price tag onto this thing
as for power yeah I get that just
releasing an A40 with 24 gigs of vram
for the consumer Market wouldn't be very
impressive next to the 3090 but this is
just ridiculous the EVGA card even has a
thankfully unpopulated second ATX 3.0
power connector which would
theoretically give this thing access to
over 1200 watts of power it's a chilling
look at a world where Watts don't matter
as long as you're getting frames
you'll note however that we didn't do
very many benchmarks to find reasons for
this thing to exist
that's because we didn't get our card
until two business days before embargo
lift and even if we got it sooner the
driver was only made available two days
before that the final version of the
reviewers guide was uploaded yesterday
Nvidia clearly did not want us to look
too closely at the RTX 3090 TI and
that's okay
because I'm not sure how much more I
need to see
the worst part about all of this is that
there's nothing that I can say or do
that will prevent people from buying it
the RTX 3090 itself is already nearly
half a percent of the steam Hardware
survey that is twice as many gpus than
the RX 6700 XT and nearly so for the RTX
3050 TI if you expanded out the desktop
ga-102 GPU that powers everything from
the RTX 3080 to the 3090 TI
represents a combined total of nearly
two percent a big enough portion to put
it in the top ten people want the big
boy I think we deserve some of the blame
for that I like how we deserve blame for
our storage going haywire get subscribed
so you don't miss our data recovery
Adventure by the way
but if you want this thing
if you're one of the people that Nvidia
says want the absolute best then I don't
know what to tell you perhaps money is
No Object and you want to get as close
to that 8K gaming promise as you can or
maybe that extra little bit of blood
envious squeezed from the stone is
exactly what you need for Peak
productivity
I disagree
what is Peak productivity is this segue
to our sponsor thanks to backblaze for
sponsoring today's video world back up
day is March 31st and if you want to
back up your data give backblaze a try
backblaze isn't affordable and easy to
use cloud backup solution that starts at
just seven bucks a month you can back up
almost anything from your PC or Mac and
access it on the go with their web and
mobile apps backlace also lets you
restore by Mail they'll ship you a hard
drive with your data right to your door
and after you're done you can return the
hard drive for a refund backlace has
nearly two exabytes of data under
management and over 55 billion files
have been restored so you can receive a
fully featured 15-day trial with no
credit card required don't be an April
Fool try it out and start protecting
yourself from potential bad times at the
link in the video description below or
at backblaze.com LTT thanks for watching
guys sorry this one was a bit ranty
I just I know it's not for everybody but
I I don't like what this represents
maybe go grab a palette cleanser with
our recent video on the grain GPU
accelerated nvme solution that one's
actually really cool